beginning of limiting calculus right i
actually launched into the topic by
talking about gradient
and the whole idea of rise over run and
what it looks like
when you've got rise over run on an
increasingly small scale
and that's why we had to talk about
limits and h approaching zero blah blah
right
well i left out was some uh
some of the building blocks that go
underneath all of that
calculus that formal understanding the
reason why i left them out is because i
wanted you to get the concept
and motivate you for why are we learning
this topic at all
rather than let you get bogged down in
some really these eddies are kind of
weird you might think why are we
why are we looking at this anyway um
we're not getting tested on it in fact
it even says in bold
it says not to be examined okay so why
are we learning it
well um first reason um these are
legitimately important
okay um they make sense of a lot of the
stuff that we've actually already been
assuming okay
and secondly even though these aren't
accessible in a direct way
okay and as i show you the concepts
you'll be like oh i see that you can't
really write a question
that tests whether you understand this
or not this will become really really
important when we look at max min
which is a big topic under calculus
later on
so i have two concepts right so let's
launch into it
the first one is called continuity
continuity simple idea i'm going to give
you a simple intuitive definition for
this first
and then i'll give you sort of a more
technical rigorous one
okay so we're talking about functions
and graphs
to say something is continuous
this is my intuitive definition
to say something is continuous i guess i
would ask does the graph
does it have any breaks
like does it ever stop and then start
again
okay some of you may have heard this is
a good way to put it
can you draw it the graph i mean um
without
lifting your pen or pencil
so okay now like i said this is a basic
idea you can think of some graphs
that work with this and some which
violate this idea
okay so clear example easy example
something like say
y equals 1 over x and this is hyperbola
so what's it look like well you've got
one branch of it
which is totally separate therefore not
continuous
with the other okay so we would say that
this graph is continuous
for two sorry two separate domains
okay we'd say it's continuous for x is
less than zero
and x is greater than zero well actually
i should say
four okay so it's continuous in certain
places
it's not like there's breaks everywhere
okay and as you zoom in it's all tatted
and you know broken
this part is continuous and so is this
part but there's that discontinuity
at x equals zero okay so that's the
basic idea
but let's get a more technical rigorous
definition
it's got three parts to it this
technical definition okay so
number one we want the function
like this to be defined at a particular
point
function is defined
now let's just give an example point
like say
x equals c where c
is just any old constant that you like
okay a real number
right and you can pick it anywhere along
the graph so
is the function defined at for instance
x equals one
on this graph yes it is so that's why
this graph is continuous
for that point and i can pick a whole
bunch of other ones the only one i can't
pick it for
is x equals zero okay so there's the
first part
now the second part starts to get a
little weird and i'm going to give you
some counter examples to help
try and understand this okay let me give
you the technical part first
um the limit
of namely
as x approaches c f x
exists and i'm about to give you some
weird words which i need to explain a
little bit so i'm just going to put it
down first
and is the same from above
or below
or end
what does this mean okay so think about
a function
let's go with something like say
uh actually i should call this f of x
when you think about this function
because it's continuous everywhere
right if i take a limit at any point it
wouldn't be that hard to work out for
instance
the limit as x approaches 0
right of f of x in this case because
there's no breaks
all i have to do is put in x equals zero
right and you get zero that's what i'm
approaching
towards zero okay however think about
this graph up here
okay even though the graph doesn't exist
at x equals zero
i can think about the limit as x
approaches 0
of 1 on x i can think about the limit
even if i can't exist there okay but
then you come up with a problem
because what would you say the limit is
equal to what are you approaching
as x gets closer and closer to zero
now there's two answers are there one of
the two answers
okay if i if i have a look at this side
right in other words if i come from the
right or if i come from the larger
values that would be
above okay if you come from above you're
getting larger and larger and larger and
larger so you would say
it's approaching infinity okay but if
you come from the opposite side you get
a completely different story
right it's like they're totally
unrelated okay so you would say
minus infinity okay so how can we
distinguish between these
what we say is we i have to introduce
some notation to say
there's a limit but which way you're
coming from okay are you coming from
above
from positive values values above it or
below from values that are
less than okay so another way of saying
this is
limit as x approaches c and then to
indicate that i'm coming from a
particular direction
i'll put a um a sign above the value i'm
approaching
okay so what would this mean this means
i'm approaching c
from above from the positive side this
is positive that's negative
right so this is sort of like uh if you
like from right to left
or as i've said here from above
now i want the limit as i approach this
this value you see from one side i want
it to be equal to
um the value from the other side i want
them to be the same
okay and as you can see like in this
example
they're not always the same so just to
fill this out okay if i was coming from
above i would get infinity okay and if i
go
from below okay
it looks a bit weird because it's like
zero positive and zero negative the
negative in the positive indicated
direction
okay of one over x that's equal to
negative infinity
okay so one of the reasons why this
function is not continuous
is not only that the function isn't
defined
okay i could define the function
somewhere i could say
you know let's just let it equal there
okay at x equals zero
it goes to the origin okay but it
wouldn't
obey the rules of this limit okay you
take the limit from one way you get one
thing you take it from the other way you
get differently
okay so even if it were defined even if
i could tick off for a
i can't take off a b it doesn't approach
the same b
so this is i'll just fill this out this
is left to right
or to say it another way from below
okay lastly what's the third bit and
it's kind of superfluous it's kind of
necessary
but it's there in the textbook
definitely so i'm gonna give it to you
anyway
um number one the function is defined
number two
there's a limit and coming from both
directions it's the same
and the third part is the function is
defined
or sorry i should say f c that's a
better way to say it
equals
the limit that above that i'm talking
about
okay so for instance i mean it'd be a
bit weird but
you know you can imagine a possibility
for a situation
if i gave you this function so this is a
piecewise function
okay so this would be f of x
is equal to what how would i define it
i'd say
it's x squared for x is less than zero
let's make it one for x equals zero
and it goes back to being x squared for
x is greater than zero it's a weird
function but let's just go with it
anyway
okay so it's sort of coming down the
limit's approaching everything's fine
and then it goes whoop
at that one value and then as you keep
going it just keeps on matching its
merry way
okay so here f of c right actually i
should go from the top
the function is defined at that point
that i'm interested in
uh the limit exists and from both sides
it's the same
but the thing that it's defined as isn't
the same as the limit so you'd say
this thing is not continuous it's got a
hole in it okay again
i can't um i can't draw it without
lifting my hand pencil markup whatever
these are the three parts of continuity
now like i said this is important later
on when we get to max min
because when you have functions that
aren't continuous that
leads to a problem for when you're
trying to find the maximum value of a
function or the minimum value
okay so take this idea of continuity and
file it stuff it away in the back of
your mind and we'll come back to it in a
few weeks
so this is continuity